[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN STEVENS: Funny
thing is that we gave Urs
20 minutes to talk about
all the innovation.
You know, I sit
about 10 feet away.
He used to be four feet away.
He's moving a little bit
farther away from me.
But he could actually talk
all day on just innovation.
And trust me, you
wouldn't get bored.
And he's the one who
sold me on coming here,
because it was just that belief
of all the innovation that
was inside Google, and they were
going to point that innovation
cannon, that cloud.
How can you not win?
And in the process
of winning, you're
redefining what the
industry thinks cloud is.
So it's been fantastic.
But on top of
innovation, Google's
really different in
another way as well,
and GCP is, we're open, right?
And that's not by accident.
It's just that we
fundamentally believe
that the cloud that has the
best features and the best
capabilities, but that's
built on open technology
and open APIs, just presents the
most value to your end users.
So that really is our mission.
And because of that, a
lot of our innovation
is just happening
externally, because it just
advances so much faster.
And when you try to do
things in proprietary,
all you're really doing
is creating friction
to both adopt and impediments
for people to actually leave.
So to us, we actually
really internalize us,
and it really influences choices
that we make on a daily basis.
So at GCP, we're really trying
not to reinvent the wheel.
If a de facto API
already exists out there
and we want to have a
similar service in GCP,
then we adopt that API.
So the whole HBase
ecosystem and technology
was created because of the
Bigtable white paper by Google.
And so when we actually
took that internal service
and said we want to host
that as a GCP service,
instead of using
that internal API,
we put the open
source HBase API on it
because it was just better for
end users to be able to adopt.
And the second is if an
open source stack is already
out there and it has really
great adoption around it,
then you're going to want to
use it in the cloud as well.
You shouldn't have to convert.
So actually we've been bringing
those in as managed services.
And when we bring them
in as managed services,
there's all this
amazing thing we
can do in terms of
integrating them, making
them more reliable, integrating
telemetry, more performant.
So you'll actually
stay for the value
and not because of the lock in.
And that's some of
things that we're
doing around Redis,
MySQL, Hadoop, and Spark.
The third is in open
source, you can't draft.
You really gotta get
involved in upstream.
If you really care
about technologies
and you're building
a platform on it,
you can't just be
downstream and consume.
You've got to get involved.
And that's what we've been
doing for years around Linux,
and now with Docker,
Chef, Puppet, Spinnaker,
Terraform, and most
recently Cloud Foundry.
And then the last
point around this
is that if there is technology
that doesn't exist out there
but we really feel like it
needs to be part of cloud,
you have a choice.
Most people just differentiate
and build it internally.
Instead we've
actually said we're
going to do that publicly
and do it openly.
And that's what we've been
doing around TenserFlow.
We've been doing it around
Kubernetes, Apache Beam,
first Apache project I think
that was created by Google,
which we think is the future
of MapReduce, and GRPC.
So we know the model works.
Open innovation works.
We've proven that.
Two of the most significant
intellectual property
areas for Google are machine
learning and containers.
And both of those,
we consciously
chose to develop them openly.
And now because of that, we've
looked at both Kubernetes
and TensorFlow.
And on GitHub, those are now
the number one and number
two most engaged projects
on all of GitHub.
And we just believe
that innovation
doesn't have to be held
for proprietary advantages.
Kubernetes and TensorFlow,
it's not a marketing stunt.
They are both
better technologies
because of that community
involvement upstream.
But it's not always about
some big massive open source
project.
Even the smallest of things
can really get in the way
and impede adoption.
And so last year right
after I came here,
I started talking to some
colleagues for the Wall Street
banks.
And what they really said
is that cloud's not done.
There's all these future
things that they actually need.
And what they want to do is now
they knew Google was serious,
they wanted to start having
more open conversations
about the advancement of
the future requirements.
And primarily these were things
around networking and security
and then how do you actually
deploy applications.
Because the reality is
what they didn't want to do
is have siloed conversation
with each of the top three cloud
providers, because
then we all go in
and implement those
things differently.
We're all going to do them.
And it just creates all this
gratuitous differentiation.
And to be honest,
that's one of the things
that's plagued the whole entire
IT industry for many years.
And so it's early
days in the effort.
We actually created
working groups.
And believe it or not,
Google, Azure, and AWS
are all in the same room
with these top customers.
And we're really trying to work
it out and have open dialogues.
So the one nice thing about
our commitment to open
means we actually get
to work with partners
in a whole new way.
It's much deeper.
Often, that looks
like partners actually
just port their products
to GCP, and we're
answering help desk tickets.
And when we really
engage around open
and our partners
are open as well,
it actually allows us to
work with them on code.
So it's really been a lot more
fun and a lot more productive.
So one of the companies
that recently we
actually formed this type of
relationship with is Pivotal.
And so Pivotal doesn't
need an introduction,
but they're the corporate
company behind Cloud Foundry.
And Cloud Foundry is a
platform as a service.
And they've done
a really good job
of helping people really convert
to agile methodology and cloud
native.
And they're having a lot
of successful on-premise
and cloud.
So Onsi Fakhouri is
here from Pivotal.
He runs engineering.
And I wanted to chat
with them a little bit
about our partnership.
[APPLAUSE]
We can stand, or set
the tone and stand.
So I can't sit, you'll
give me massive shit.
So how did the relationship with
Pivotal and GCP get started?
ONSI FAKHOURI: Sure.
So we had a mutual customer
come along and say,
I really like Pivotal
Cloud Foundry and the value
that it gives me.
And I'm really liking GCP.
Can I get these two
things together please?
And so we started
working together,
codeveloping on a
solution to really launch
PCF on top of GCP.
And it's been just
really, really powerful.
And now we're seeing
growing demand for it.
So that initial seed has gone
on to bear a lot of fruit.
BRIAN STEVENS: So tell me a
little bit about two things.
One, so what's that
collaboration felt like working
with our engineers?
Two, what's the experience
of sort of new to GCP?
What has that felt that?
ONSI FAKHOURI: So, I mean,
it's really blown our minds,
the level of collaboration.
Jay Marshall, Eric Johnson,
Evan Brown, these folks
came in-- San Francisco, the
Pivotal office in San Francisco
is just across the street.
And we had these
folks from Google
show up, sit down
with us, pair with us,
working day in and day out to
really perfect the technology,
get it working, and
get it deployed.
And it was just really
incredible collaboration.
It sort of blew my mind.
We had to make some
changes to PCF.
We also had to make
some changes to GCP.
And they made those changes.
It was like, what?
It was really impressive.
And then something
something crazy happened.
So we deployed
PCF on top of GCP.
And then one of my
engineers came to me
and said-- he came up to
my office and was like,
"Onsi, can I give a talk?"
I'm like, "Sure,
you can give a talk.
What do you want to
give a talk about?"
And he said, "I want to
give a talk about GCP."
I was like, "Huh?"
And you know what happened
there was an aha moment.
So here's this engineer
who's been working
on other IaaSes for
a while, and he's
had this first
experience with GCP.
And he goes, "This
is just so different.
It's elegant.
It's thoughtful.
It's performant.
It's stable."
Performant and stable are
really important for us.
We have CI pipelines the
drive IaaSes really hard,
like bring them to their knees.
And so if they're flaky
or if they're not up,
my developers are
not productive.
And we saw this opportunity
to jump onto a platform that
was super productive.
And then I started
to dig into it a bit.
And you know, the value
per dollar, again, just
off the charts.
And so we saw an opportunity
to really sort of pivot over.
And the nice thing
about PCF is that for us
and for our customers, you
know, we're cloud agnostic.
You can run on AWS.
You can on the Azure.
You can on GCP.
And so making that move,
it's just very easy.
And so we're now
very eager customers.
And we are,
internally at Pivotal,
going to be moving many
of our workloads, most
of our workloads over to GCP.
And we're just really excited
for where this partnership is
going to go.
BRIAN STEVENS: So what's next?
ONSI FAKHOURI: Well
lots is coming.
I don't have anything
to share today,
but in the next few weeks we
should have a lot of good news
to share with you all.
BRIAN STEVENS: Awesome.
So I will say that there's
a lot of assignments,
there's a lot of
stuff that needs
to be done in engineering,
and not all of it
is fund and glamorous.
There's a lot of dirty work.
And when we actually started
putting people on Pivotal
and working on Cloud
Foundry, I think
they're some of our happiest,
most engaged engineers,
and they love working
with your team.
ONSI FAKHOURI:
It's just been fun.
It's just been really fun.
So that's been great.
BRIAN STEVENS: Awesome.
ONSI FAKHOURI: Awesome.
Thank you.
Have you a good one.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN STEVENS: So the
transition to the cloud
for a born in the cloud
developer or a startup
is actually pretty
simple because they
don't have to go through
a transition at all.
But for most businesses,
you have a large legacy
of installed applications,
infrastructures, networking,
administrative
methodologies, developers,
and just institutional
knowledge.
So one of the things
that we actually
think about at GCP a lot is
what's that path to adoption
look like?
What can we actually
do so it doesn't
look like this separate
thing, and how do we actually
find what's creating the
most impedance and friction
and eliminate that?
So I want to talk a
little bit about that.
And the story goes
back eight years ago,
because the first cloud
service that Google had
was Google App Engine.
And as Urs talked about,
it's an amazing service
because developers can
publish these services,
and they don't have to
worry about anything else.
They don't have to worry
about the reliability
because we take care of it.
They don't have to
worry about scaling
up because we take care of it.
Scaling down, we take
care of it, all the way
back down to zero.
They aren't hiring
database administrators.
And they aren't dealing with any
of the other underlying issues
and managing OS upgrades.
It's a really powerful platform.
And the end result is you get
this amazing service at scale,
and your operational
burden is near zero.
But for some, that jump to
PaaS is just a little bit
of a bridge too far.
And sometimes the
easiest pattern
for the first part
of cloud adoption
is just to have an
API around a VM.
And that really
makes it much more
easier to consume because
you're already doing
that inside your data centers.
And that was really
the mindset on why,
even though we had a PaaS
is why we invested in IaaS
and why GCE came
out three years ago.
And obviously now
that seems right,
because internally
when we watch and we
look at the growth of our
platforms, when we measure it,
GCE is one of those
services that we actually
measure with log scale
just to watch the growth.
So I think obviously it's really
helping enterprises a lot.
But we don't actually see
this as in, you see a lot
in the world like, it's a silo.
It's a platform as
a service choice,
or it's an infrastructure
as a service choice.
It's really not that way at all.
What we're finding is people are
coming to us initially for GCE,
and what then they're
doing over time
is they're adopting service
by service for zero ops.
You might start on VMs, and then
you start to use a managed load
balancer, or you're
using a managed firewall,
or then you start to
use our auto scaler,
or then you start to use our
PaaS for any type of database.
And so you never
really made this choice
of what silo I'm in.
You really just found the
easiest pattern to adopt,
and then you actually grow into
more of a zero ops environment
as you go.
And the story's kind of
similar for networking.
When you think of
how cloud originated,
it really was just a
separate subnet in the cloud,
all with public facing IPs.
And now with GCP, we
recognize that's not
the right model for enterprise.
So what we've done is
now when you use GCP,
it looks much more like private
subnets in the cloud, all
with private IPs.
You can easily bridge
those together.
You can easily put a
firewall in front of them.
And then most importantly,
you can actually
bridge that network right
into your on-premise network
without transiting over
the public internet.
So it feels far
more like cloud's
evolved to feel far more like
it's a data center extension.
On the container side,
we talk a lot about that
because that's
just our language.
Google grew up on containers.
Developers inside of
Google don't really
know about infrastructure.
They wouldn't be
productive if they did.
They're just publishing their
code in services, on the board,
and they get everything
else for free.
And that's why Google
invested so much
in cgroups over a decade
ago, because cgroups
was that technology inside
of Linux that allowed
that isolation to happen.
So you get multiple containers
on a single Linux image.
And it doesn't provide
the security isolation,
but it provides the
needed resource isolation.
And that was the first phase.
And now with Docker,
the container movements
are light, because on top of
that Linux kernel isolation,
now what you're getting
is application confinement
and application portability.
So it's really powerful.
And so you actually can
Dockerize applications,
containerize applications
and deliver them
across multiple platforms,
multiple OSes, multiple clouds.
That's really liberating.
It's really, if I
had to compare it,
it's really what
VMware and Linux
did long ago by normalizing
onto our hardware platforms.
And now Docker's bringing
that to a whole new level.
And so you have to think
that five years time,
10 years time, transcoding
VMs as a method of migration
or portability from one VM
format to another has to end.
So this is really great
for the IT industry.
But what it needed was a
management and orchestration
system.
So think about how you would
manage ASX in your environment
today if you didn't have
either vSphere or vCenter.
So because of that, contributing
Kubernetes to open source
was just the obvious
choice for Google,
because if we don't, it'll
hold back the ubiquity of what
this container movement can be.
And then second, all these other
different bespoke solutions
for managing
containers will arise.
And so you won't really get
sort of the standardization
that you want around
management and orchestration.
And so kind of calling
it done right now.
Like Kubernetes
has really become
that de facto management
system for Docker.
And you see that on GitHub as
the number one most engaged
project.
TensorFlow was second.
Third was actually Docker--
really powerful trio.
And so this week actually
marks-- it was on Monday,
the release of the open source
Kubernetes 1.4 milestone.
And hoping for a great GKE
launch of the same tomorrow
actually.
And the one nice thing that
1.4 brought was federation.
We've been working
on it for a while.
Pieces have been coming
out in the prior releases.
And what that allows you to
do is now with containers,
it allows you to have
multiple clusters
of containers all managed
with a single control plane.
And it's a really powerful
thing because these clusters
can be on-premise.
They can be in the cloud.
And in GCP, they can be
multiple zones in the cloud.
So what you get
out of that is it
makes it really simple
for a developer.
A developer, with
one command, can
publish a service, a container
based service, that's
multihomed across
multiple clusters,
sitting behind a single
static IP address.
And then our global
load balancer
can route to the right
cluster based on latency,
based on capacity.
And so you get this really
powerful low latency, high
performance solution without
any extra operational costs.
And this was a big thing.
I didn't figure out what
Pokemon was on Friday night
when Sunder made the
call that there basically
our QPS was spiking.
And one of the tools
that we actually
used to help that
out was actually they
were one of the earliest
consumers of the federation
capability, meaning
multiple zones of GKE.
And you're going to
hear the whole story,
I think this afternoon.
So I'm really proud that open
source and Linux is a trusted
enterprise platform.
You know, I spent almost
13 years at Red Hat.
It was my personal mission.
And it was just because I so
believed in that Unix paradigm,
which became the Linux
paradigm, and that Intel
like commoditzing underlying
hardware underneath made sense,
and that it had to be open.
But the on ramp to
cloud is bigger.
It's a heterogeneous
environment out there,
and it includes more than Linux.
It includes Windows.
So Windows has really been a top
priority for GCP for some time.
We now have Windows Server 2000.
We have 2012.
2016 I think is
coming in October.
We have a full .NET stack.
We have Visual Studio
for developers.
We have PowerShell support.
We have SQL Server images.
We have license portability
that Microsoft supports now.
And we build .NET clients across
all of the GCP APIs to make it
easier for developers.
So we really think that
this marriage of Windows
with all the amazing
things inside of GCP,
like fast bootable custom VM
shapes in the fast network,
it really all of a
sudden means that GCP
makes this awesome
platform for Windows shops.
So more on friction.
The first adopters of cloud
naturally are AWS users.
And what we found though
is that a lot of AWS users
come to GCP because
of the differentiation
that Urs was talking
about earlier--
you know, these faster VMs.
We have these shapes that you
don't have to be stuck to,
a set of specified core
sizes and specified VM sizes.
You can actually pick
an arbitrary shape.
Our sustained use discounts,
because people, believe or not,
don't love RIs.
Our private global
network-- you know,
no need to schedule reboots
because of live migration,
and the BigQuery analytics
that we talked about today
that makes Redshift kind of look
like a departmental warehouse
that you have to
manage yourself.
And so a few years back when
we were saying we really need
to bring monitoring
capability to GCP,
the acquisition we made
was a company, Stackdriver,
that was running on AWS> And
one of the choices that most
companies would make is say I'm
going to move that completely
to GCP and then use that for
a point of differentiation.
Instead we said, we've
got enough differentiation
for when users are
actually using GCP.
But if it's going to be
this multicloud world,
isn't a better
service for our users
if they're going to
be using AWS as well
that they're going to have a
single monitoring, alerting,
and logging backplane
that works across all?
And so it's a bigger
investment on our part,
but that's what
we're committed to.
And so I love this
Uber quote, I mean one
because just it's a great
quote about Stackdriver.
But even more importantly
to that, what it signifies
is that even in the
cloud world where
we're doing so much of the
managing of the infrastructure
and the managing
of the services,
end users still want telemetry.
It's not like, make it
all work and don't tell me
how you did it.
And so that's what we're
trying to give with Stackdriver
is, even as we're
orchestrating services,
even when, if you've
picked a solution that's
patching your OS, you
still need to know that.
And so a big part of Stackdriver
is how do we actually
expose all of the telemetry
that's happening inside
of GCP so that it makes sure
that you have full awareness?
So cloud has really made
infrastructure programmable.
You don't file a
help desk ticket
to get a server any longer.
You use an API.
We've now made everything
programmatic-- firewalls,
virtual machines, networks,
you know, the network,
any data store you want.
So it's quickly becoming
a foregone conclusion
that infrastructure
is now programmable.
But to really realize the
dream, the next phase,
that has to extend into
applications and services.
And we're making progress.
Developers now packaging their
applications under containers
is super helpful for that,
because now they're lightweight
and they're portable so
they can be automated.
And then you bring
in Kubernetes,
so now you can manage that
whole container environment
without managing the
underlying infrastructure.
So the third phase that
I'd say we're kind of in
and we haven't really
figured out as an industry
yet is really how
do you actually
represent microservices
and services,
and then how do you
actually wire those together
and deploy those as an entity?
So there's a lot of
choices on how to do that.
We have some.
There's a lot out there.
But the industry hasn't
really consolidated
on what that de facto
model for that is.
And so I think that's
the next phase.
And unless you unlock
that, then you really
hold back a lot of
the standardization
and we move on to
solving the next problem.
So at GCP, obviously we
have UIs for everything.
But we're putting
everything behind an API.
So we're putting
infrastructure behind an API.
We're putting all the services
behind an API, microservices,
and application stacks.
And so we really think
that Cloud and GCP
are enabling the next generation
of what an ecosystem is
going to look like.
And so the reason
I think about that
is the days of the selling of
binaries and software stacks
as a commercial
ecosystem-- you know,
it leaves a lot to be desired.
Nobody likes receiving
stacks of software
that they have to configure,
et cetera et cetera.
But what people really want
is what happens after that.
How do we actually start
to consume capability
through a service
and through an API?
And so we really think
that's the future
of the commercial ecosystem.
And we're really at the very
beginning part of that journey.
It's like, how do we get out of
delivering stacks of software,
even in the cloud,
because they're still
kind of doing that as
well with the ecosystem.
And instead what
you're doing is you're
provisioning
capability from the API
and allow people to consume it.
And that's a big reason
why we acquired Apigee.
Because what we
want to do is make
it easier for businesses
to take their services
and enter that into
that API economy.
At the cloud providers,
from an API perspective,
we're already there.
But there's so much value
that businesses can have
if they can bring their services
into this new ecosystem.
And Apigee is so far ahead in
figuring out a lot of this.
Their API management
deals with all aspects
of authorization and security.
It deals with DDoS.
It deals with integration.
It deals with quota.
It deals with billing.
It deals with specifying an SLA.
And those are all the
facilities that you
need if you really want to enter
this business to business API
economy.
And so GCP users are actually
going to be able to now,
when there's Apigee
powered services,
they can actually integrate
them whether those services are
running on another
cloud or whether they're
running on-premise.
And then likewise builders that
are actually building on GCP
are going to be able to use
that whole Apigee framework,
and they're going to
easily be able to publish
their services through
the Apigee APIs
to meet whole new markets.
So as you might
expect, Apigee and GCP
have a lot of common customers.
It's not really that surprising.
So I actually want to introduce
you to one of those customers
today.
So please welcome Naveen
Krishan of the Home Depot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAVEEN KRISHNA: Hey Brian.
BRIAN STEVENS: So
tell us, Home Depot's
really making this digital
transformation, right?
So tell us what that's like and
what that mission's all about.
NAVEEN KRISHNA:
Yeah, for us, it's
all about connecting our stores
to our digital properties
and providing our customers
a fantastic experience
in their home improvement.
That's what digital
transformation for us means.
And we call it interconnected
retail internally
within our company.
And from a customer
standpoint, it's
all about making it easy
for them to research
the problem they're trying to
solve, research the products,
buy the products wherever
they want to buy it,
get it delivered when they
want to get it delivered,
whether it's picking
it up in the store
or delivered to the house or
get it delivered same day.
That's really from a
customer standpoint.
BRIAN STEVENS: So how does APIs
and Apigee fit into all that?
NAVEEN KRISHNA:
Yeah, I mean, we've
been using Apigee
for a few years now.
You know, you look at our
interconnected solution
platforms, they're
pretty much all
based on Microsoft's
[INAUDIBLE] architecture.
And its both services that are
internal facing and services
that are external and customer
and third party facing.
And when you think about
the scale of what we run,
it's nearly impossible to
manage it through people
and manual processes.
And so that's where
something like an API gateway
comes into play.
And right now we use
it really for external.
That's because we
have this hybrid model
of something's
running in our data
centers or something's
running in the cloud.
The more we move to the
cloud, it reduces the latency
and it creates a better case
for leveraging something
like an Apigee.
BRIAN STEVENS: So
you're an Apigee user,
but I hear you're
also a GCP user.
So how are you using GCP today?
NAVEEN KRISHNA: Yeah, I
mean, we are early stages.
GCP is one of our cloud
infrastructure solutions.
Early stages, been using
GCP for about 18 months now.
Been very good so far.
It's, one, the scale
of what Google runs on.
So getting that sort of scale
of infrastructure is awesome.
And then also some
of the offerings
that come out, things
like Stackdriver
that you just talked about.
We tend to like to want
to be an early adopter
and try things out.
Many things work well.
Some things don't look as well.
But overall, extremely
pleased with how it's going.
BRIAN STEVENS: Awesome.
So funny story, goes
back a few years.
But when I actually
had to pick what
I wanted to go to college for,
I wanted to be a carpenter.
And my guidance
counselor said no.
And so I had no other interest.
So I did computer science.
And so I have to admit,
I'm a little bit jealous
that you've combined both
of these fields together.
NAVEEN KRISHNA: In
our Palo Alto store,
we have an opening
for a carpenter.
BRIAN STEVENS: There you go.
Thanks Naveen.
NAVEEN KRISHNA: See you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN STEVENS: So it's
absolutely very compelling.
And we think this
is actually going
to be the spark of
the next journey
to really create an API
economy for just better
business to business.
And so we're not going to create
Apigee as a proprietary silo.
We're actually looking,
like how do we actually
integrate that, as we retool
that, into all of our currents
we've around open source.
So you'll be seeing a lot more
around microservices and APIs
and endpoints emerging
in open source
and out of the
Kubernetes efforts.
Because when you think
about it, it's actually
five worlds converging.
It's the cloud.
It's open source.
It's containers.
It's these microservices
that are building out
of the Kubernetes stack.
And it's commercial APIs.
So today, like it's
all around open.
It's all around innovation.
It's all around how
do we actually work
in a more frictionless way with
our partners and our customers,
like how do we figure those
things out and make it easier
to adopt cloud, and how
do we actually build
this new commercial ecosystem.
So the past years have
been really exciting,
and I actually think
the next few years are
going to be even more exciting.
So thank you for that.